There's no music!
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Yeah, the menu is really cool though, right?
It's mesmerizing, just like the bugs outside my window.
Oh my gosh, you guys, there was like...
I was looking and I saw this like white cloud that was
like...
And I was like, is that and I was like looking at it at
first I was like oh no is it smoke is it like a fire and
then I was like no maybe it's like a really really really
really really big spider web that like detached and it's
like floating in the wind and then what kind of bugs I don't
know I don't know and then I like looked even more and it
was like there's like a film grain on it so I was like oh my
gosh It's like millions of bugs.
Just millions of bugs in a cloud.
And they're all like...
And I was like, whoa!
Forget about the buses and the bugs.
Now you need to focus on the bureau.
How can I forget?
How can I forget about the buses and the bugs?
There are no buses.
Wait, why are we talking about the buses?
Confession, whenever chat is yelling hold, I just imagine
these little Ibu with pleading faces reaching up and asking
to be held by Minto to comfort them about being late.
I was a little late, sorry.
Hope you enjoyed Jesse Control and Control all over the
place.
I'm ready to control things, baby.
Mic-Mac, thank you for the gifted.
Hi, Minto.
I have Minto ice cream.
Share?
May I have a bite?
This is one of the most visually striking games I've ever
played.
Glad to see you getting into it.
I'll be honest.
i know so little about this game i know that i did like the
you're upstream thank you i think when bugs make clouds like
this it's mating ritual so they were probably i said the
same thing i was like oh my gosh like they're probably doing
nasty in the air and i'm watching and i can't stop watching
ready to control things but you already control my heart
but yeah i did i've done like the okay here's here's i am
excited for the game but it's so funny because when you go
to steam and you're like about the game or whatever they're
like this game has won 80 awards and it looks really good
and it's a good game and that's literally the description so
i was like okay all right cool and then and then at least
there's no spoilers so true and then I saw some people
saying it's kind of like if you like SCP stuff you'll be
into this which I'm I'm interested in that about the game
it's good yeah yeah these games are best going in blind I so
I started Alan Wake because I had heard such amazing things
about Alan Wake too so I was like well I can't play Alan
Wake too without playing Alan Wake.
So I was like, I will play Alan Wake.
And then everybody was like, whoa, whoa, whoa, hold on.
Minto, if you want to play Alan Wake too, you have to play
control first.
And I'm like, all these things are getting in my way.
I'm playing Alan Wake too.
And so I played Alan Wake.
And I needed, I'm going to be honest, I needed a bit of a
break from from from mr wake afterwards i of course enjoyed
the series so much but um boy golly that game got a little
tedious sometimes so um so i was like do i play control
sometimes this is how i sometimes weigh things this is how i
weigh things sometimes sometimes i will
annoying comments are worth it mentally to me or not you
know so so for example if i were to jump from alan wake into
alan wake 2 would i get a barrage of people being like you
didn't play control and so you're not gonna understand this
and that and i would just be like i don't want to deal with
it so so instead i'll just play control and then that i
don't have to deal with it you know what i sometimes i like
weigh my options in that regard where i'm like do i just
want to not mentally have to deal with any barrage of angry
comments from people so but people have been really hyping
this game up and the second one is coming out soon so what a
great time to play it right so um you're playing control for
the first time yes this is the first time and use a
controller oh my god stop i already thought of that joke
because i wanted to specify that i am not using a controller
this time i usually play these games with the controller i
looked it up and people were like no no this game is better
with mouse and keyboard and i'm scared because i usually
play control
controllers like there's only like three four buttons i can
push you know what i mean there's like or you know what i
mean like there's xyab there's left trigger right trigger
there's lb you know aiming does suck on them it does but i
don't get so lost in the sauce other games keyboard mouse
games sometimes like i know you can keep you can re-bind
keys and everything but sometimes I'm lazy and and sometimes
the keys are all over the place if something tells me to
press X on my controller I know where that is but sometimes
if they're like oh no but this to use this thing instead of
a instead of usually just playing X or pressing X you have
to press F but in another game it might be R in another game
it might be E it's time to play control try foot controllers
on third person games just feel better that's how i feel
right i don't know maybe i'm like a traditionalist who knows
but this time i will be playing mouse and keyboard at least
for this time unless it gets so frustrating for me but i
would like to um just specify that because i don't usually
play mouse and keyboard with these types of games so it's
gonna be a bit of a learning thing for me the kingdom hearts
dilemma vtuber did you not watch the 11 hour mobile game
movie on I know, I know!
Always press Alt at 4.
Actually, that's so true.
If you ever need help with your game, Alt at 4 will solve
everything.
Anything that needs aiming sucks on controller.
Yeah, but I played, you know, like, I played all of Metal
Gear on controller.
Even V!
Like, I played Alan Wake with controller.
Like, I don't know.
If something is built with the intention...
of it first like you know obviously with ports and
everything that's a different story but and nowadays things
are made for like multiple consoles at a time so you can get
away with mouse and keyboard for a lot of things but if
something is made with controller in mind I always think
that I should play with the controller I don't know I for
inventory B for bag L for loot yeah right Adam I'll to a
bamboo ship thank you hmm keyboard mouse people are very
weirdly insistent that everything works better a keyboard
mouse i'm not saying that anybody uh says that or said that
to me or anything i just looked it up because i was like i
wonder i don't know
but yeah you know whatever i'm gonna try for this one at
least so um bear with me
Hi Vendoo, the VTubers found Doki Bird due to the World Cup.
It's been a fun ride on her side.
Now I'm checking out her OPS.
Hi, welcome, Kagyu.
Welcome, welcome.
The World Cup.
That's so funny.
That's, welcome to VTubers.
Oh, geez.
I mean, what's so much different between a VTuber and a
streamer?
I don't know.
I'm the weirdo who pushes for gyro aim at every...
offense.
I'm playing with tilt controls, obviously.
The irony of that statement when technically American
Nightmare and Quantum Break, listen, you'll be fine without
those two.
I know.
Trust me, I had people being like, are you going to play
American Nightmare?
Obviously, there will always be somebody that will ask if I
will play a certain game in a game series.
You know what I mean?
always listen to the demands of of the imaginary people in
my head but but um yeah i don't know so i know some people
were very well not some people i know that rather i have
heard opinions of people that are very insistent that you
should play control before alan wake to and that's okay i
you know i wouldn't have known either way um without people
telling me to so i don't mind it so much i don't mind it so
much this game is actually connected to the leisure sweet
larry universe you have to play all of those games first oh
well time to switch up time to switch up the entire stream
everybody vtuber why aren't you playing with hota's play
what is why am two people telling me oh my gosh yeah
this leads into stein's gate zero
i mean i could get my flight stick actually it had that
weird drift it had a weird drift last time i tried to use it
no it all leads to metal gear i just uh yeah it's not really
a big deal or anything i just kind of try to give you guys a
little bit of insight into my into my noggin sometimes if
you ever get too frustrated wait if it ever gets too
frustrating the difficulty options are very customizable
even make yourself immortal if you want to no way i've been
playing leisure sweet larry would be peak ops opposition i
saw you blew up doki yesterday and i'd do it again
yeah a tour of my mind palace yes did you install the
drivers for your flight stick oh let me install let me yeah
let me reinstall the drivers for my ps2 flight stick you're
so right
oh a suit oh you're so right i read it as sweet uh this game
is connected to school days i heard wait featured them both
I'm also technically in school days did you guys see wait no
I think it was at the end of this year there was announced a
like school days concert and I was like oh wait I might be
going to Japan at the end of this year so I'm gonna try and
go and I was gonna be like hey I voiced like Kumimori the
bully I'm a very important role in this series.
Can I please?
Can I please get a ticket?
Please get a ticket.
Hi, I'm Vinto Hagapo.
This game is actually connected to the dinner and a movie
universe.
Want to give that a try sometime?
I'm not familiar with that one.
Is it connected to the Flintstones?
Yeah, where would they be without my role?
How would this story even exist?
Without...
No, the Jetsons.
Meet George Jetson.
Boo-boo-boo-doo.
Daughter Judy.
Doo-doo-doo-doo.
Jane, his wife.
Boo-boo-boo.
I don't remember the rest of the song.
Control is actually a part of the Kojimaverse.
I believe you.
Play it with Guitar Hero Controller.
Wait.
That would be sick.
You actually have to watch Better Call Saul before playing
this game.
Actually, I did.
I implanted it.
I watched all of Better Call Saul through YouTube shorts.
So I think I'm all caught up.
I did it.
But no.
I but what I was trying to I think what I was trying to say
was I'm it wasn't that I was like skeptical of control but I
didn't know anything about it and I really just wanted to
play Alan Wake and I was like okay well I guess I'll play
this so I'm kind of going in blind but with hopeful optimism
so I really truly know nothing um and uh yeah so no spoilers
please or anything um you're gonna love this i like this
game a lot more really wait i'm so excited for control two
then well i'm sorry wait i shouldn't say that i haven't even
what if i hate this game what if i'm like man everybody what
if you guys are collectively trolling me and you're all just
like yeah let's say it's really good and then she'll play it
and like i have to feel like she says it's really good too
because everybody loves it and she says she hates it that
will be mad at her she thinks will be mad at her so she'll
be forced to say she likes it
oh i'm not spoiling but i want to say i like your outfit it
suits you well thank you i like to go a little dork mode
sometimes what was the last game you could say you hated you
know what i didn't i don't hate this game no no i shouldn't
say this i shouldn't say this never mind um last game i said
i hated
oh walking dead season two i mean maybe
walking dead season two no well i didn't even play it though
i only played like the first chapter I don't know if I if I
hated that I would it's hate is such a strong word I feel
like it's it's hard to use it you know what I mean haven't
played this but I suspect you are not being one guide by all
the guys would that be all guide yeah right the remedy games
are the only ones that I have ever planned them on ps5 whoa
that's a that's a crazy like achievement though hmm it's
worse meant they turned the walking dead into a show oh that
you were mad at the Subtitles?
I already added that.
I already went through the options.
I turned off...
I added subtitles.
I turned off motion blur.
I'm ahead of the game.
Very excited to play Control 2.
I've never played a Remedy game.
Someone who has played 70% of Remedy games.
IMO, this is the best gameplay-wise.
Very fun.
I'm cautious of Control 2.
I think it'll be good.
Winnie the Pooh Home Run Derby?
No, I can't hate that game.
Happy to see you to play this.
Take control.
One thing I did do was I muted the copyright music.
So if you were expecting to hear some songs, they might not
be in them, potentially.
Unless you think it's okay.
At the first chapter, Walking Dead was enough to put you
off.
That's enough.
I need to be a plumber to know when something is shriek.
No?
It should be fine.
I would take the chance.
Lady Gaga?
Wait, I can't get got by Gaga.
Best music is made for the game specifically.
Da Gaga.
What about Awaria, the ghost kissing game?
No, I wouldn't say I hated it.
I get frustrated in the moment wouldn't mean that I'm not
having fun yeah I think it's very I feel like I can make it
quite obvious when I'm like there's a there's a point where
I'm like angry but it's it's like a and then there's a point
when like I'm frustrated and I'm like
you haven't watched me so much but also i try not to get
like so upset on stream that i'm like you know not wanting
to be entertaining at the same time i mean obviously i'm
only ghost i i can't help it sometimes that's in my nature
to be angry and upset and and all that you just got god god
but i feel like there there are times when i'm like like oh
this is not fun anymore and I feel like sometimes I probably
make it quite obvious.
But usually, even if I'm like, ah, it's not like a, it's
usually at myself more than the game.
Because I'm like, oh no, I'm so stupid.
Hey, Mito, I just wanted to say thank you.
Just finished my master's degree.
And he absolutely helped keep me from losing my mind.
Keeping your cool self and I hope you enjoy control.
It is a criminally underplayed game.
Jackie Bend.
Congratulations.
Congratulations!
You're masters!
You're a doctor!
Doctor!
There is a very cool original song in the game.
Well, that would mean...
That would mean...
copyright music off, no?
I have to tell you this now.
The copyright music is in two to three sections and you need
it in one of them.
It'll be mostly fine otherwise.
we could try it with anyways and as whatever I mean if I get
copyright struck as long as my channel I've said this before
I don't really mind if I get copyright struck because it
happens quite often but as long as I don't get like a like a
like there's difference between like a copyright strike and
then like a strike on your channel you know what I mean so
um and I don't have ads on so I don't make money from that
anyway so um yeah it's all good
as long as disney doesn't come for you exactly exactly yeah
yeah as long as they don't also yeah like delete the vaude
that that always sucks i wouldn't want to mute it in that
case as well but um doesn't apply for that one song so it's
not a big deal cool well cool shall we get started then
claim versus strike i let me see let me see the verbiage
they use
honestly had a really fun time with control and would
definitely recommend it to folks and say often go it's on
sale right now actually oh control and like there's like a
control if you if you watch me play and you are interested
in playing for yourself this and uh like an alan wake bundle
are on sale right now for like six bucks and also control by
itself is on sale for like two dollars so three dollars yeah
so it's very very affordable right now if you are um
sponsored no i wish uh yeah it's very affordable right now
if you um if you are wanting to play it yeah i actually like
i saw it earlier i was like no way i don't remember how much
it was when i bought it but uh definitely not that much i'd
get your for subs now with code boomer you could do that you
could do that thank you for playing one of my favorite games
you can leave copyright music on you won't regret it okay
thank you andy thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you is this the complete adult ultimate adult edition do you
imagine if i had the adult edition have you guys ever i mean
i'm sure you guys have i've only recently have seen like the
mods that people have done to like tifa and final fantasy
and i'm maybe putting maybe putting games on pc was was a
mistake but yes this is this is the the ultimate addition
the postgame dlc is arguably more important to the extended
remedy verse than the main game or no kidding when i see the
ketzel koatlas pop up in my store in your store it makes me
think of you getting excited the trailer for lost wilds i'm
so excited for that game oh my gosh new hold on i i already
wishlisted it but i had like some people send it to me
there's like a new a new dino like i don't want to call it
mascot horror game it's called terrible lizards and it's
coming out october 29th and you like work at some like
museum some like but there are some mascots in it but like
the dinosaurs start coming to life and stuff And I'm like,
oh, no, I think I'm so, I'm kind of pretty excited to play
it.
The adult edition is for the leisure suit, Larry connection.
Wouldn't that then be like birthday suit, Larry?
Do you know you have to have a revolver in this game?
I did not know.
I don't know anything about this game.
But now I know.
Thank you very much.
Enjoy Minta, one of my favorites too.
Thank you so much.
I will.
Hmm.
No, this is my first time playing.
control i know nothing of it so yeah made in a lab to appeal
to mint truly
lost wilds outer wilds outer worlds i'm so confused all you
have to remember is outer wilds it's the most important one
it's the most important one we thank you welcome back for 28
months thank you thank you Thank you.
Outer heaven?
Well, we're going, everything is just trying to be out.
No thing is, nothing wants to stay here.
We're, we're, we're just, we're, we're just going, we're
going outwards.
It's really weird talking to you guys with no menu music,
I'll be honest.
I maybe should have put on some BGM or something, but in her
mouth.
there are just some games that will never leave my
consciousness a little late but congrats on the concert it
was the best day of my life and i cried real tears love you
lose guys thank you thank you i feel like like you know as
much as i said alan wake i needed a break from it afterwards
especially after that dlc holy cow but um it's like one of
those games that like ingrained into my brain you know what
i mean alan break yeah after alan wake i was like okay i
need a bit of a remedy break um an outlet break uh but you
know like i even if i'm like oh gosh this is so tedious oh
gosh like the alan wake dlc i was there were parts where i
was like okay I'm not really having much fun with this
anymore, but I still that even not even something like that
Will make me hate a game, you know for the DLC therapy bill.
Thank you Just saying to reassure this is not a horror game.
Oh I wasn't sure actually I think it does it have it seems
to have like some creepy elements But I guess is not a
horror game per se.
Um Glad you took that break for your Alan's sake
I'm another year older and grateful to the Minto con I guess
that means it's your birthday Happy birthday Happy birthday
It's creepy but not horror It has no jump scares Awesome Two
years Takuma thank you Thank you so much This game is one of
the purest power fantasies ever created It's not perfect but
I love it What does that mean
oh god let's go in then i'm excited everybody's just kind of
like we're all just kind of discussing it but it's time to
actually experience control so oh oh oh um i think i already
did all these yeah so yeah i already adjusted all of these
so i think it's okay movement is critical critical to avoid
sustain well i guess i don't need that hint when do we get
to play as minto and metal gear this is gonna be weirder
than usual weirder can't be helped i'm just a weird quirky
girl you called me so here i am jesse
this this game takes place in new york right or something i
know i shut you out sometimes I'm always glad to hear from
you Weirder It's just that I get my hopes up Yeah So many
times it's led to nothing Gosh yellow shirts are in or
something Both dudes are wearing them Everybody gets your
yellow shirts in It's like We live in a room And there's a
poster on the wall Uh-huh We stare at it and we think that's
the whole world.
The room and the poster.
The portrait of the guy with his back.
The picture is something nice.
A landscape, a famous person.
Like in that movie.
What is it called?
The prison movie.
The room's a cell.
And the picture, it's different for...
each of us it can be beautiful or terrible but we're all
transfixed whoa but it's all a lie something to distract us
from the truth they're lying to us it's the january to
ourselves the rooms not the world the world is much bigger
and much stranger how's the audio by the way There's a whole
hidden behind that poster that leads to the real world.
We all feel safe in that room.
But sometimes...
Sometimes something crawls out from behind the poster.
And the ones that see it happen, freak out.
And try to forget what they saw.
This feels quite matrix-y.
I'm here.
Why did you bring me here?
Oh, I'm lagging hardcore.
Oof.
Hello?
Anyone here?
Hmm.
Well, the game's not lagging.
It's just me.
Let's see.
What can we fix before we continue?
Sorry, guys.
Oh, blrrrrrrrr.
Uh.
Like I have everything on Miriam.
Chee-be time might be.
We'll see.
Where's the v-sync?
Oh, wait.
I guess...
Oh, did it just...
Oh, it just turned it off.
Oh, okay, okay.
I didn't even see the off.
I was like...
I only saw the medium high ultra and I was like...
Wait, but...
But I don't even see an option to turn it off.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's just see if that works.
Cool.
Oh, meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow
meow.
Just turn the render resolution down to 1080p, baby.
You know what?
Baby.
Wait, where was that?
Sorry.
This?
I don't have.
I didn't even see it because it was all...
It's blacked out.
I do not have.
Turn it on.
I don't have it.
I don't...
Though there's a V-sync.
Oh!
I don't know if it's...
Okay.
Yay!
We're so back.
I'm moving.
Ooh, the sensitivity is kind of crazy.
Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hey, nobody had to.
There's nobody had to.
Thank you, guys.
Playing soccer.
That's the guy we just saw.
All right.
I didn't see if there was a...
Hold on.
just see if there is a oh there's a photo mode if there's a
sensitivity um thing brightness if we okay no sensitivity
okay well oh here it is here it is oh i completely skipped
it let's go to like 40.
okay okay that's already so much better
security check beep beep what's that prohibited items g to
open my collectibles
correspondence certain objects are not allowed inside of the
bureau here's the future Minto's supercomputer fund but
thank you controller beginning with controls I see you
cojumbo yeah i still i have not had time yet to set up like
my dual pc setup which is like so crazy to me that to think
that i still need that because i feel like i have such a
beefy computer but whatever recent incidents have
necessitated an issued reminder on prohibited materials
unauthorized weapons pagers laptops smart watches
smartphones uh smart gaming devices anything smart does that
include my metal glasses number two pencils any objects
considered iconic representations of an archetypal concept
example rubber ducks and ketchup bottles okay wait what
anything smart good thing good thing wait that means wait
but they let me in
they said what they said yeah no rubber duckies allowed.
Iconic representations of an archetypal concept.
I don't know how rubber duckies and ketchup bottles are
related.
All material under Bureau investigation is to be brought in
through the private entrances.
If you see any lobby personnel in breach of these policies,
please notify your supervisor immediately.
Who's bag is that?
Mr. Glitchway, thank you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, automatic opening door freaked me out.
Oh, internal lockdown in effect.
Building lockdown in effect.
Multiple containment breaches detected.
Multiple building shifts detected.
Head of research override.
HRA protocol activated.
That don't sound good.
Metaglasses are fine.
Those are stupid.
Is that my powers?
I can open the door, but with...
Oh.
What's going on in there?
I guess I could open the door and find out.
This seal.
I saw it a long time ago.
I keep seeing it in my dreams.
Silent Hill.
I dream of that seal.
Whoa, oh no.
Is this like...
You guys said this wasn't a horror game.
This...
Oh, wait.
No, maybe these are...
I thought they was refuses.
These are like those...
Oh, this is...
These are the things that go...
And they go to another...
Another place.
Oh, whoa.
Bureau expenditures.
Staffing...
Oh, major.
Staffing surveillance.
Bip, bip, bip.
Data Center Initiative Construction Minor Office Equipment
Janitorial Cost Mold Removal Okay, I'm sorry, that should be
under a major Numeric twos Is that what they're called?
They go swoop They do, they do For a cost breakdown
spreadsheet, see page 5 For a five-year comparison chart,
see page 9 Okay
Why are you telling me how to sprint, huh?
Head of research, Dr. Casper.
Aren't you a little darling?
Whoa!
I'll pay for that.
I'm so sorry.
How much do I weigh?
Wait.
Um.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, look.
They're looking at me!
Uh.
The floor is fragile.
yeah a little bit I just wanted to see what the gaming
magazine was game about secret agents oh yeah what's this oh
Zachariah wait so oh no here's the our Bureau at work oh
interesting is this a oh federal Bureau of Control all right
last these years I've been looking for them and they were
hiding in plain sight.
Oh, toilet?
Nothing in here.
Nothing here.
Alright.
Yeah, title drop, baby.
Where's the door?
See, it's crouched, no?
Okay.
I thought...
But it's not even letting me crouch.
It almost looks like...
Like a tiny opening.
Oh, I did it again.
I am quite literally the people that run into...
Into, uh...
Uh, glass windows.
You are a bird.
These remind me of, like, the Lumen snacks.
From, uh, Severance.
Pistachios.
Potato chips.
Protein, protein, fibers, fibers.
Fuckers, trail mix.
Hot and spicy.
Something or other.
Nice.
Can't find your office.
Watch your step.
I'll take the trail mix.
Oh.
I can zoom.
Hello.
Where is everybody?
I'm getting a little freaked out here.
Is this?
security order attention to all blank a shark in his
although secure permission to following basic protocol shoot
to kill good luck
shoot to kill
janitor is
he is he See the shark?
Hello.
As you all should know by now, the R4 reports are due by the
end of the week.
We're still waiting on them from a number of people.
If you need an extension, please request form r4.e from your
supervisor.
If you think you're exempt from filing an R4, then you'll
need to get written permission from your department chief
saying so.
Remember, R4s are mandatory under Section 75.2 of the
employee manual.
interdepartmental claims then please contact the appropriate
department head dr. darling miss Marshall mr.
Salvador mr.
Kirkland as needed they'll be busy on Thursday and their
annual policy review so please schedule accordingly the best
your admin team what is an R4 report his
life is in your hands let's work hard everyone's safety
depends on you just remember chat the people who made this
game series are very much from Finland Yeah, they are.
Hi, Min.
Hi!
Thanks for the super chat.
Comes after the R3 report.
I see.
Hello?
Hold on.
Hey, excuse me.
Excuse me.
air pods in there you are you are here about the job ati
janitor's assistant you need to go to the interview go that
way to the elevator thanks youtube studio oh yeah thank you
very much very good i'm at the janitor by the way you'll
work for me okay you can say i sent you If they don't hire
you, Ada, you are no hell of it.
There be work for the axe.
Take them behind the sauna, you are allowed.
Take them behind the sauna.
I've done enough night shift loner jobs to know it makes us
come off weird.
Welcome to the fold.
The janitor is a friendly face in my book.
Better than somebody with no face at all.
How did he hear that?
Think about it.
No face.
Am I talking out loud?
What, that said?
Oh, I know what you're thinking.
If there's an axe murderer around, that's him.
Ati?
He just does that.
I learned recently that saunas are very important in
Finnish.
Seek shelter.
That's so scary in Finnish culture.
Wait, if everybody's seeking shelter and there's a breach
and everything, what's our guy?
doing here he's reading the subtitles no way hold on was
there whoa
wait oh wait wait oh I was about to say how did it get so
dark over here the building has a
Has shifted?
Wait?
Wait, what?
How did it do that?
Whoa, how did it do that?
Whoa!
Proceed further into the bureau.
But this is all still the same.
Oh, gosh.
Even my hole in the ground is still there.
All right.
spooky wait the handprints whoa freaky why is it upside down
the cell and the poster I was 11 years old the first time I
saw behind the poster they pulled me I imagined it I've been
trying to pull it down ever since will you help
Oh, opening sequence.
Control.
The title drop.
Federal Bureau of Control.
That's our guy.
William Afton.
Oh, red bean's scary.
Whoa.
Not Sam Lake.
could be whoa whoa sam lake alan wake
neat sam wake alan bake did i lose you there for a moment
you know what's on my mind my baby brother dylan i knew that
i know that person since the men of this bureau took him.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, I was like, why can't I move?
But it's really just not...
Oh, there we go.
It wasn't letting me look around.
Zachariah Trench.
Zachariah.
Cool looking tree.
Some meese.
The wow, wow whiz.
You hear that, Zach?
Zach?
Oh, that doesn't sound...
My bad.
Sorry, I'm very clumsy.
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
This machine is remotely controlled and may start without
warning.
Oh, missions.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jesse Faden arrives at the oldest house, the headquarters of
the Federal Bureau of Control, to look for answers to the
mysteries of her childhood.
Approved terminology reminder.
While pending any notifications of death related to the
willow awe please adhere to the following guidelines this
game is my favorite single player game in the last 20 years
it's like the x files back rooms doctor who had a weird baby
what that's a crazy description it's the sam lake alarm
don't mind word slash phrase to use in the service of his
her country regret proud pride will be remembered words
phrases to avoid
don't belong in Alaska.
Scissors.
Blood bleed.
Loss.
Apologies and sorry.
Sorry, Alaskans.
Oh, I love just standing on stuff.
Oh, I don't even have a one clearance.
Oh, wait.
Oh, just kidding.
Sounding awfully spooky.
here you guys anything sorry i'm such like a oh wait i saw
something didn't i oh i saw that over there just kidding i'm
such an explorer i'm like trying to loot goblin when i don't
even think there's loot to goblin what's that sound it
sounded like almost like this but i guess not Good to
explore in this game?
Okay, good to know.
Right now, it doesn't seem like...
Like, it seems pretty obvious when there's something to...
Ah!
When there's something to look at!
Like, it kind of gives you a very obvious circle.
Uh, what was I doing?
Uh, unmapped area.
G.
Barbara.
I am not to be disturbed.
Cancel all my appointments for the day.
For the rest of the week.
trust them, Barbara.
Not a single one.
I guess that's everything, huh?
Is this his office?
Office of the Director, Zachariah Trench?
Shit.
Oh, my God!
Shit, shit, shit.
Uh...
You want me to pick it up?
The murder weapon?
Really?
Who's telling you to do that?
Something's outside.
What?
No, it was coming here a mistake.
I guess we need...
You say it's a murder weapon, but...
The hoomst.
Experiencing the lore in this game will be fun.
And there goes the poster.
Objects of power can cause...
or be results of a we's altered world events intrusions upon
the perceived reality now the service weapon is of course a
prime example yeah we got real people a very powerful one in
the Bureau's DNA a key component in our prime candidate
program come out of that Russian roulette a winner and you
you're it
All of the board's instructions to complete the Astral Plane
Challenge.
What the...
Oh, no, I have a health bar.
Okay.
The house is...
You occupy.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Wee!
Over there.
Eww!
Are you coming this way?
Melee.
Oh.
Vee!
That's...
What the...
Wait, wait, wait.
Look at this thing!
Ah!
Where's your neck, buddy?
Oh, there's my gun.
A gun.
There's a gun.
The same gun.
Freaking obliterated, yeah.
Whoa.
Okay.
Now I have a gun.
Nice, all right.
Fire service weapon.
I will when I need to.
Oh.
Dang, he's tough.
Do I have, like, unlimited ammo on this?
Nope.
Just kidding.
The service weapon regenerates ammunition automatically when
not in use.
Oh, got it.
That's what I figured.
Yeah, it recharges.
Alright, where are they?
I'm gonna punch him.
Punch!
Wait, I punched you!
I punched you!
Punch!
Yeah.
Oh my goodness.
Get out of here.
What was that?
More guys?
Or...
Oh yes, more guy.
Oh, wait, you have a weapon too!
I don't like that.
Wait, why do you have a weapon too?
Oh, what's this?
We held the gun you, me?
Yeah, I only am allowed!
You guys have to be funky little...
Weirdos.
Uh, don't have guns.
Name Dokomito.
Shut up, I'm nervous!
An attack.
Duty is director.
I'm not an FPS player.
You can only dunk on Doki's aim.
You can't dunk on mine.
It's not allowed.
Did you hear that?
It's the dead man.
Right after the pyramid spoke to me and it was just noise
and I understood every word.
And this gun's alive.
Congratulations, Director.
I'm happy.
Happy to be here.
Me too.
Proceed further into the Bureau.
outside is it safe to go is it ah uh sure
you can't let this happen you can't let this happen you
can't let this happen
the blend of like Whoa.
You stopped it.
You...
Oh, thank you.
That was...
Horror.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Get the fuck away!
Yeah.
Enemies drop health elements when damaged.
Collect health elements to restore health.
Wow, no kidding.
Oh, like that thing?
What was that?
Where am I to go?
That is locked, closed, and locked, clocked.
What do we got here?
Oh, hiss guard.
Whoa, the bureau has many internal security personnel.
The hiss was quick to take advantage of this fact.
Locked.
Little dots are the health.
The marked items are materials.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
That's what I thought.
Guards use the standard-issue bullpup rifles they carried
prior to corruption, while the armored guards carry
pump-action shotguns.
Where do I get a shotgun?
They have no observed paranatural abilities, with the
exception that certain hiss guards are protected by a shield
of dense hiss resonance.
Capable of stopping bullets.
It is shielding a result...
Wait, is this shielding a result of prolonged hiss
corruption?
Does the hiss mature in organic hosts over time?
More data is needed.
did the hiss targets and target individuals with combat
training does the hiss have that level of cognizance
cognizance does it utilize hosts for tasks they are best
suited to combat trained hosts are reserved for combat these
are all questions for later though it is obvious that
corrupted individuals retain knowledge on their use of
weapons refer to file for full report
this guy's picture.
So much is expected from the director.
The responsibility, the privilege.
Service weapon.
Oh, my thing.
The object was discovered inside the oldest house.
In the room that is now used as the director's office.
Whoa!
That blank of their wielders.
Wait, what?
Oh.
If rejected, the applicant is terminated.
Whoops.
Darling prison.
Oh, we got that one.
We watched that.
Yeah.
All right, cool.
Well, we're going.
I still can't do it.
Right?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Oh.
That's me.
How did they update it so fast?
wait gosh she looks so familiar like the actress the hiss
something smells snaky oldest house discovered August 4th
1964 promotion yeah okay
whoa that doesn't look too good Oh.
The hotline.
Secure line of communication.
Guidance.
Reach the hotline.
Those are the full darling videos.
You just see a snippet.
Okay, got it.
Says the dead man.
Okay.
That doesn't look so good.
Good.
Dang, that's a good photo.
Wouldn't they take that?
Delays caused by house shifts do not count towards overtime.
Spinning out of control?
Yes.
Acoustic guitar for sale!
Turns out it's pretty hard.
If interested, see Greg in maintenance.
Reminders of all staff, food left in the refrigerator and
containment break rooms.
Room 3B has been known to vanish.
This does feel so SCP.
Don't get from my Facebook.
Don't bring dogs into the office.
Some of us have allergies.
And it's not for any, like, paranormal reason.
Say hi to some new people in the oldest house.
Look at all of them.
Are those devs?
That's so cute.
Wash your hands.
Your hands can spread the mold.
But the mold was not very serious, was it?
They said so.
The mold was not a top priority, apparently.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Yep.
Are those guys gonna come down too?
Ah!
Recharge it, please.
Oh my god.
My aim.
Don't say anything.
Ammo?
Where is he?
We're fine.
These guys aren't going to stay up there, right?
Or are we okay?
They're scared of me.
I'm nervous about them.
They're all just speaking.
They're chilling.
Push the fingers.
Oh my gosh, there's so many of them.
Oh what they drop?
What's this?
kill boosts undefined reading okay all right let's see what
we got going on around here
this is what i do most of the time at work when i work to
office uh same here executive meeting minutes they shouldn't
be attacking me i am the director of this establishment
Hey, who's making all that noise?
Oh.
If you experience an unanticipated building shift, follow
these simple steps.
It's muted.
One.
Search the room for any altered items or objects of power.
Two.
Carry the altered item or object of power to the nearest
safe room.
Three.
Wait for bureau staff to find you and the object.
altered items or objects of power in the vicinity then reach
your supervisor via the nearest intercom and await further
instructions and if no intercom
what did we get weapon mods
whoa i guess i mean wait what was the other one astral
reload efficiency oh plus 16 reload Wait, what was the other
one?
Damage after kills, 33%.
I mean, either's fine, probably.
Oh, wait.
The other one, this one's rare!
Oh!
The reload is rare.
Cool.
Wait, and we have our own personal mods.
Oh!
Wow, we've already found, like, boost.
Wait, the Astral Health boost is also rare.
Nay!
They're being so nice to me.
me uh rising costs of awe response update on mold
eradication efforts i told you guys the mold should not have
been a lower priority this is why i'm director now this is
why i'm director upcoming annual salary review new supplier
of coffee filters to be found and vetted please come
prepared thank you for your time
We can go into the bathroom.
It's allowed.
It's unlocked.
Maybe.
I like how...
Well, I guess it could be locked because due to all the
shifts and whatever, right?
Toilet vapor.
Jump scare.
I don't like all of them talking.
They talk too much.
You can use your melee attack to break stuff.
Like the toilet?
I was kidding.
Holy.
You don't need this anymore, right, guy?
You don't need this anymore?
Wait, what's this here?
Oh, more reading material.
Give me something to break.
Oh yeah, we already listened to that.
Oh my god!
You shouldn't have told me this.
She's gone mad with power.
Okay, wait, there was another, sorry, there's so much
reading material in this.
Wait.
Never mind, it disappeared.
Oh.
Weird.
Okay.
Move fast, break stuff.
I'm so like, I'm such a slow gamer though, like,
legitimately, but I'll do my best.
Don't let mold hitch a ride.
Yeah, I work here.
Dinner reservations at 7 p.m.
at Chez Ambre.
Wife will meet you there.
Don't be late.
Flowers are ready for you at lobby reception.
Remember, she is turning 46.
What's this 4?
Me?
I have a wife.
And I'm missing my dinner reservations!
Because I'm at work!
And now I've been given a job I didn't ask for.
What's this?
Oh, watch your step.
Oh.
Awkward.
Why?
Marshall, A.W.
What are you doing in here?
What is this?
More undefined reading?
See, okay.
Probably, right?
For Marshall's eyes only, Marshall, we have checked out the
suspected AWE in Duluth.
Wasn't anything.
Just like the house fires before this and the malfunctioning
clothes dryers before that.
My team is getting pretty sick of duds.
The dud.
Subject.
Another dud.
We need to find a better way to sort the fake AWEs from the
real things.
Or you need to rotate these field agents off for a bit.
Mold.
Minto only loves destruction.
Anyway, we're on route to Sherman Ranch.
Next one on the list.
Let's hope it's a little livelier there.
Sincerely, Special Agent Kingdom.
I have a feeling that Sherman Ranch had everything going on.
Nabnite!
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Get there!
Thank you.
Nothing in there?
Or was it the thing that I grabbed?
The name of the sound.
Okay.
Oh wait!
What was that?
Oh.
Where's my snacks?
So cool.
It looks like you'd have a nice nap up there.
Note to self, don't get between Minky and our dinner
reservations.
Why can't I speak today?
Memory doesn't fail.
The floating people talk in your system language, not your
game language.
So even if you have the game in English, you'll hear them
talk in Spanish or German.
Whoa, that's cool.
And that's fixed.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Welcome back.
It's so creepy.
Ah!
Central executive.
The hissing sound that tried to invade me earlier.
The hiss.
into everything in this place is the hiss your enemy all
right it's our enemy okay
visitor evaluations start with the following welcome to the
bureau of control established in 1964 as part of an effort
to strengthen government relations how vague our enemies i
say this all the time i say this all the time we are proud
to serve the united states and her people as we strive for
transparency and excellence in all aspects of our esteemed
nation's infrastructure.
If they do not leave, then ask them these questions.
One, are you here to see someone?
Two, are you from New York City or just visiting?
Three, how'd you find this place?
If their answers are sufficiently harmless, explain that
this is a secure federal office and that they'll need to
leave.
If their answers seem sus, escort them to a private room.
There perform the Gunner's Psychological Assessment.
The JPA.
If the responses are within the acceptable range of deviance
see the provided scoring sheet then blank them immediately
remember there's no such thing as too suspicious prepare of
the insanity yeah we got that hiss going on that babbles
contagious it burrows in like an infuriating melody that
makes you hum it over and over that guy looks particularly
dangerous he's pulsing
Legends.
Oh my gosh, there's so much to like collect and read.
Urban legends are believed to affect the creation of altered
material, but can also dictate the characteristics of an
altered world event.
Wow.
So we could get Mothman.
Urban legends are understood as the modern evolution of
Jung's archetypes.
We recognize certain informed by our own and popularized by
our media.
We have traditionally provided that urban legends can be
artificially in popular culture using our bureau made
anthology television program once the seeds are sown human
imagination exacerbates the details certain paranormal oh
sorry paranormal phenomena contain clear elements of
popularized folklore a w is that only occur on a pair of
scissors that consume human through two punctures on the
these details living in the minds of so many have been given
strength through belief.
Urban legends are not just stories for children.
They are paranatural realities waiting to happen.
It's pronounced like young.
Oh, thank you.
Young.
Refer to file 493-6924 for full report.
Bigfoot Israel, exactly.
Oh.
Is this copyrighted?
Am I gonna get in trouble?
Maidbinto is quite an anomalous entity.
Sussie Baka.
Like a bolt of lightning.
Can I get this guy from here?
Oh!
My bad.
Oh, they're down.
No!
Wait, what?
What's going on there?
Okay, oh shoot.
Sorry, I didn't see you there.
Wait, I guess I can just climb down, but I'm scared.
Anybody else?
Where'd he go?
Oh my god, you're a tough guy.
Okay, okay, Tuffy.
All right.
Ah!
Where's the other guy?
Where'd that other guy go?
We don't need two guys.
Ah!
What to deal with.
No!
Please!
His... he became so red I couldn't even see anything!
Yeah, I should go grab the health Oh, come on.
The hissing sound that tried to invade me earlier.
Do these all...
I guess I've picked them all up again.
Okay.
Is the hiss your enemy?
Blah-blah.
Right.
It's our enemy.
That babbles contagious.
It burrows in like an infuriating melody that makes you
Hummet over and over.
Yeah, keeping your pickups is pretty nice.
So, let's just take out these guys real fast.
Oh.
Was there...
Oh, oh.
Yeah, he disappeared.
Okay.
And so when I go down, I guess another guy, two more guys up
here?
Director Vicky, listen up.
This is critical information.
You need to...
Bunky!
Okay.
I see some health over there.
I should probably go grab it.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Alright.
Freaky guy.
Where's he at?
Oh my gosh.
Oh
my gosh.
Please recharge.
Don't come over here.
Don't do it.
Okay, I grabbed this stuff.
Oh, hello.
Whoa.
This is such a cool effect.
Oh my god.
It's schnauz.
It's right there.
Yeah.
So this is a control point.
I'm cleansing it.
Oh, I'm fixing it.
I got this.
Remember to melee.
Thank you for the reminder.
Whoa.
I'm controlling.
you did it we did it interact with the cleanse control
points to fully restore health on death she will oh the Pope
the Pope talking to me oh I have different outfits whoa
astral dive suit talk to me we saw you deal with the
compromised agents it's her sneaking suit whoa is it safe to
come out who's talking to me oh you hold on person just be
yapping oh um wow
free snacks no I lost of my ability.
Hello.
I can't tell you how happy I am to talk to somebody sane.
Her feelings mutual.
I'm Pope.
Emily Pope.
Oh, okay.
My turn.
Should I lie?
Jessie Faden.
Oh, she didn't lie.
I'm just visiting.
I'm just lied.
Oh, shit.
You're the new director.
Yeah.
We're coming out.
I don't know how that happened.
Alan cake.
Director.
Faden.
Call me Jesse.
Okay, Jesse.
I'm Emily.
Hi, Emily.
Look, somehow this hostile force.
Trying to sneak around.
That works.
Somehow the Hiss managed to infiltrate the building without
any warning.
And just like that, my name for it is official.
The Hiss.
Wow.
like the sound of poison gas leaking in it it's kind of a
dumb man it seems to have spread everywhere and to everyone
not protected by an hra and extraordinarily you you are the
director and that makes you special by definition trench is
no longer the director obviously i'm sorry i'm talking too
much this whole situation is i think she's nervous a lot
trench is dead Shot.
Ah.
I found his body.
And the gun.
Do I tell her it looked like a suicide?
The service weapon.
Persona!
And this can sound crazy.
But he keeps appearing to me.
Saying things.
It's hard to make out, but he told me to cleanse the control
point.
Yeah, I did that.
The whole room shifted around.
Her face looks weird.
Yeah, she looks a little...
Pope looks a little uncanny.
What was her name, Emily?
Before you became the new director?
How?
Ah.
I'm not ready to tell her about you yet.
A janitor let me in.
Yeah, that's so true.
I love it.
This is fucking unbelievable.
It's...
My question.
Emily.
I can't even...
Look, Jesse, I have a million questions and you probably
have a million more.
like do you know my brother Dylan not yet not yet there's
something but I'm the director you to do if you can cleanse
a control point then you can maybe cure those infected or
possessed by the hiss because if that's possible our options
are very different Emily Pope I don't know her but I like
her already okay She's the opposite of the faceless agency
I've blamed for what happened to me for so long.
But I can't trust her yet.
Or rather, the bureau she's a part of.
Jesse, what is your eyelash routine?
Everybody's got these crazy long eyelashes.
I'm speaking for you, of course.
We can try it together.
Isn't that right, Zach?
We'll try it together.
You with me?
Hold on.
We did it before.
Push the hiss out.
Okay.
Cleanse the hiss corrupted agent.
Dang, this is a great suit!
Wow.
What if we just literally push her?
Oh, it was behind her.
Oh, oh, uh-oh.
A Thanos?
It didn't work.
Oh, it did.
Hiss has burrowed too deep.
Ripping it out, rips them apart.
Ooh.
That's awkward.
Jesse, over here.
We need to make a plan, Jesse.
Okay, stop talking to me.
What do you think this guy's doing?
This guy obviously has a job.
What is this guy doing?
Turn to ash.
I mean, ash.
he's leaning jesse we need to cook yes i can't cleanse them
i saw it was worth a shot thank you director jesse director
jesse i like the sound of that i'm gonna tell it why i'm
here we are i'll risk it oh listen the bureau was involved
in an incident in my home town ordinary ordinary 17 years
ago the Bureau came in and covered the whole thing up I've
been looking for this place for a long time that's enough
maybe that's too much already I can't tell her about Dylan
and the rest yet I've seen mentions of an altered world
event case dealing with ordinary you were at ground zero as
a child yeah it was one of the big ones and before my time
and very classified i can try to dig out some old files for
you i'm the director so yeah you better casper darling would
know but he's missing darling i think he knew this was
coming or suspected well she's oh came up with the hra's the
veteran resonance amplifiers i think they're what saved us
Ah, these things are the way I was wondering.
Trench.
Yeah, that guy's dead.
Ghost or whatever he is.
He mentioned something called the hotline.
Said I should find it.
It's another object of power, like the gun.
An old Bakelite telephone?
A direct line of communication between the director and the
board.
Maybe he can talk to you more clearly through that.
I mean, Trench has years and years of experience.
He might know how to destroy the hiss.
Where is the hotline?
It's kept in the communications department through the mail
room.
It's part of this sector so we can access it even with the
lockdown in place.
We'll get the door open for you.
Thank you.
That's my next stop.
That's Tama's department.
He's head of communications.
I don't think he had an HRA.
It does feel so.
This game, the whole game feels very SCP.
Keep an eye out.
They call me the director.
director.
But that's not me.
I'm not a director type.
I'm not a leader.
I'm just a weirdo.
Why am I here?
I think you already know.
Yes, I came for my brother, but there are other reasons,
too.
I said I was looking for answers, but I might never
understand them.
I'm not looking for proof.
This is already it.
More than enough.
No matter what they told me all those years, I know it's
real now.
I didn't imagine this.
The phone, the hotline.
I want to be a part of this world.
What scares me shitless is that I finally found it.
Only to see the hiss destroy it all.
He's dying.
Yeah, we came at the best day.
Good job, Jesse.
Your timing is impeccable.
Someone's calling.
Moshe, Moshe.
the director has been calling this whole time or wait maybe
we're calling the director like please pick up please pick
up look i know this is all new to you so don't hesitate to
ask me anything you want to know there are no stupid
questions the door to the comms department is just outside
the boardroom back in the lobby okay they should have gotten
it open by now thank you very much the signs to the mail
room you can get to the hotline containment chamber
See you back here once you have the hotline.
Thank you.
Oh, what's that one?
I'm guessing these are all old directors.
Is being bald a requirement or a suggestion?
What's this?
Weapon armor damage.
I guess if it just go bald.
Yeah, already, yeah.
Whoa, whoa, wait.
There's so many things.
Health recovery.
Health recovery per element pickup.
Plus five energy.
I don't think...
I know what that is yet.
Huh.
And weapon mod.
We've got damage while...
Oh, low on health plus 30%.
Low health boost.
Weapon armor damage.
Damage against enemy armor plus 40%.
Hmm.
Flip a coin.
Is Minky looking up or cake checking?
you'll never know you'll never know oh the energy is gun
ammo oh I see I see I see I wasn't sure if it was like a
energy power thing that I haven't unlocked yet the hotline
should be in the communications department is there a
bathroom wait origin of the hiss where did the hiss come
from I'm not sure you said the hiss was here when you
entered did you see anything like that outside before you
came in no no just inside yeah the source is internal then
oh someone said I don't think that's correct energy is
relevant later complex oh well then openings to other places
as well I don't even know where to start looking but in the
context it's good news the lockdown holds the his escaping
the building would be the end pretty shitty world out there
if you ask me but I wouldn't want the his to destroy it with
you on that
She says that, but I've seen the trailer for Control 2.
It's complicated.
Oldest house.
You mentioned the oldest house.
What is it?
Just ignore half of what they say.
This building, the Bureau Headquarters, the oldest house, is
a shifting place.
You've seen it.
It transcends its physical limits.
It does.
I've been to New York a few times.
New York always be changing, too.
It's an attribute of the building.
This is a place of power.
The oldest house doesn't like attention.
So unless you're purposely trying to find it, you don't.
Which is perfect for us.
The work we do here is essential, but...
Unstable.
The Bureau prefers not to be noticed.
I imagine that things are gonna get a little crazy.
So without you, I never would have found the front door.
Okay.
This trench guy.
I keep hearing him in my head.
Happy birthday to Hatsune Miku.
Is there a ghost?
Haunting me?
Yes.
I doubt we're talking about a ghost in the traditional
sense.
Echo maybe.
See, if he was killed by the service weapon, your gun, maybe
it's his final thoughts recorded by the bullet in his brain,
like a deep space probe sending back data.
But that's just a hypothesis on my part.
I need the gun to research it.
I don't take my gun.
You better hold on to that given the circumstances.
Uh, yeah.
I think I will.
Yeah.
Gosh, Jesse looks so familiar like an actress and I just
can't I can't place it oh I this I don't I like I know she's
probably based off like a real person but she's an actress
she's on NSIS in some soaps she's been on some soap operas
oh yeah I imagine she's a she's a real person hmm Courtney
Hope I'm gonna look her up
Courtney me hope
I'm like obviously I recognize the name the young and the
restless but I don't hmm yeah I don't know she's from the
walking dead no way are you just saying that there's no way
she kind of looks like widow from avengers it must be that i
think i think it really is that widow oh i just realized my
fan isn't on no wonder i'm so hot widow avengers i think
it's that who plays maybe it must be like the orange hair
right oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's Scarjo.
Oh, it is Scarlet Johansson.
You're right.
Hmm, maybe it is.
Maybe it is Scarlet Johansson, then.
I know it's not her, but Scarlet Johansson.
But she looks...
Oh, she doesn't look like Scarlet Johansson.
It might just be the hair.
I don't know.
It's driving me crazy.
It's driving me crazy!
Can you tell me what an object of power is?
exactly this is all she looks like my wife new to me Wow
okay I love stop bragging so objects of power are mundane
objects that house Paranatural energies and have developed a
link to the astral plane and can thus be controlled which is
what differentiates them from altered items which are still
housings of Paranatural forces but are more volatile and
cannot be bound in the got it it's her job jesse it's her
job to know this stop don't be a hater my single trace thank
you for the gifted thank you there we go thank you for the
back at the thank you nerd mint loves redheads who doesn't
love a redhead lucky thank you so hra stop you from becoming
his way it seems that way i mean i hadn't even heard of an
hra until a few weeks ago when Dr. Darling started handing
them out.
Oh my God, Emily's mouth gets so big sometimes.
It's scary.
Each one seems to emit a powerful short-range frequency way
beyond anything I've ever seen.
Doesn't the timing seem suspicious?
Why is Emily's mouth so large?
I thought that too.
Jesse's is fine.
Dr. Darling usually likes to unveil his latest breakthrough
in big presentations.
With these, he just passed them out.
His behavior makes me wonder what exactly he knew.
Hmm.
Okay, bye.
I'm sure I'll have more questions soon.
You can't just ask that, Vito.
Why is your mouth so big?
Toggle map.
Well, I did see some people complaining about the map in
this game.
And that...
I saw some people being like, you should...
Oh, look at that, thank you.
Communications department.
that the map in this game is not great the better to eat you
with sector elevator oh that's me
what's this oh come on i'm the director i'm the director is
that a stapler or an altered item don't take office
equipment outside of the building look at that little guy
he's ready to cause He's ready to cause terror upon the
people.
What is it?
Oh, what?
Is it a... Oh.
Is it SCP jukebox?
Yeah, he wants to cause mischief.
What does it do?
Why are there no files?
Nothing.
Turn around.
Why?
Is it gonna do something at me?
Hmm.
Okay.
Let's continue onward.
I think I've searched.
Wait?
Yeah.
I have searched.
Unless...
Whoa!
Did you see it fall?
That was fine.
This is where we came from.
Everybody's still floating.
They can't be saved.
It's too bad.
and wait this is different too now I mean I can't go in but
okay let's go
minimal damage we're fine they seem chill yeah oh
there it is again our welcome message
house memory
What is it saying?
Oh.
Oh my gosh, I can't go in anywhere.
Cool.
That's no good.
That's actual first, like, dead person.
Oh.
I didn't know if they'd see me.
Complete mission one.
Whoa.
Thanks.
Flash!
Oh my god.
Oh, spooked me.
Give me some health, please.
Thank you.
And I'm guessing there's some more over there.
There's so much sound.
Travel costs.
Very important.
Now shut up!
Oh, did that guy just move?
Oh wait.
Did something just appear?
Trying to find the health of the guy killed out here.
Doesn't seem like there was any.
That's lame.
This all looks very bad.
Oh my god, you're so loud.
Where'd he go?
We charging!
Okay.
You got health down here?
Thank you.
Anything else?
You got a thingy?
Oh, there's another door I can go through?
I'm just looking for stuff to pick up before I go to the red
area.
We charging?
And we can go through this area as well.
Dead letters.
Oh, these are bathrooms!
The bathrooms!
I forgot to melee and destroy everything.
It's worth it, it's worth it!
Going in here.
House memory.
What is material for?
No.
You do not have clearance level yet.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
Hidden trend.
House memory.
Boy, I have some unread things.
Melee is so good.
Oh, the only person you should fail is yourself.
Thank you, Zachariah.
The hiss manifest in human hosts in numerous ways.
The most common and least intense form is seen in the many
corrupted agents floating throughout the bureau.
The hiss agents have maintained their human appearance
undergoing no obvious physical transformation.
The most notable distinction from an unaffected human is the
fact that they levitate.
That's the most noticeable?
Yeah.
I fail myself every day.
Thanks, Zach.
No, no, you don't.
No, you don't.
The game's lore is so good.
It's so interesting so far.
What is over these strange bots?
I'm kind of confused.
Hold on.
Let me get rid of another one.
Oh, go away.
These hiss have displayed no aggressive behavior.
They only seem interested in vocalizing the strange
incantation in infinitum.
Perhaps these vessels are only meant to propagate the hiss
corruption, like spores or Wi-Fi boosters.
Or they are cocoons, preparing to enter their next stage of
evolution.
I sure hope not.
When attacked, hiss agents disappear, perhaps entering a
state of invisibility or undergoing a transformation in a
purely resonant...
I don't even try attacking.
Maybe I should have.
Research is ongoing.
Refer to file for full report.
Hiss barrier.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
There was one more thing.
Oh, this guy.
Just more health.
Everybody's so noisy here, though.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, correspondence.
I'm confused where I'm supposed to see these.
Oh, here.
Just kidding.
Oh, the travel costs.
Where are we going?
Visited the following Nevada accommodations.
Desert Sun Inn, Big Sky Motel, Starlight Motel.
In and out!
I want to go to in and out.
Bathroom reading material.
Aztec Court, Sleepy Bayer Motel.
Silver Spurs Ranch, El Gato Blanco Inn.
A plus lodge.
Accommodation at $831.29.
Meal $714.84.
Gasoline.
$295.12?
Minibar, $313.61.
The boys in research said performing rituals may help
identify any places of power.
Drinking those little whiskeys is my ritual.
I do wonder if a motel called the Ocean View is going to be
found in a landlocked state.
But hey, I guess I'm not paid to think, right?
And for the record, I again request that you give us the
budget to get two rooms each night.
tired of sleeping in the same room please be aware due to
recent fluctuations in the nearest control point this area
stability has been downgraded to yellow reference chart
green stable yellow low possibility of unanticipated
building shifts orange high likelihood of an unanticipated
building shifts red frequent unanticipated building shifts
okay yeah thinking's overrated I don't pay you to think
mister Where is the lunch?
Coffee.
As the new director, I would like to... shut up.
Oh my god, I would like to tell everybody to shut up.
Every Sunday is now a quiet day where we stop talking.
And if you use your voice, you're fired.
I don't like that there.
Let's go the other way.
Let's go to the other red zone.
Let's go to the other red area.
Oh wait.
Oh, here's a shelter.
There's a lot of sound going on in there.
What is going on in here?
Excuse me, I have to read.
Havana summary.
An auditory event occurred at the United States Embassy in
Havana, injuring the majority of diplomatic staff stationed
there.
Blank deaths were reported, and the outgoing information has
been managed.
A party.
Bureau agents arrived at the embassy on the same day as the
event was reported through federal channels, but were too
late to witness the AWE, which is reported to have been...
Blu-blu-blu-blu-blu-blu.
Staff experienced sudden intense vibrations and noise
accompanied by an intense pressure in the ears, lasted for
minutes.
No visual phenomena was witnessed.
The scene was cordoned off, and the embassy staff were
transported to the continental U.S.
After Formula I-point-9, this was recited in the vicinity a
single cowboy boot began to vibrate, identifying it as an
altered item.
The item was contained and brought to the Bureau for
examination.
The cowboy boot.
How does something becoming all... What is going on in here?
Should I be...
Whoa!
I don't think I should go in there.
It's a mold!
Oh my gosh.
My first order of business as director.
Wait, what was that up there?
What is that?
Wait, how do I get up there?
Huh.
Maybe through here?
Oh, yeah!
We got something.
More reading material.
What do you mean I'd have to get it later?
Okay.
I don't know what's worse.
This area or...
Or the other would, but uh, we'll try this area.
Okay,
never mind, we go the other way then.
Sorry, I really don't know my own strength.
Okay, we'll just go to this scary dark and red room, no
problem.
We're at the dead letters, it sounds very nice.
And hospitable.
Oh, that's a control point, no?
Oh my gosh.
I'm a little scared.
Machine God.
Alright, hold on.
We have a couple things to read.
Machine God, I had a dream.
And I built the thing.
thing I saw in my dream.
A machine that will contain God, but not the God you know or
the ones anyone knows.
A new God.
This machine will be his body, his heart and his mind.
I made it just like the dream showed me.
Why do I feel like this is a darling, that darling guy?
I use the motor from the refrigerator and the coils from my
toaster and the fans, plus the timing belt from my car's
engine and the wheels from my son's skateboard.
No!
No, your son won't be able to...
to shred god can't move yet but the dream said he would
learn how on his own this is just a beginner's body almost a
baby like a baby's but a machine instead god only needs a
place to start
god can shred now if you want to interview me please contact
me on the address on the envelope my phone doesn't anymore i
had to use the dialing plate on god on god on god bestie
oh flimsiest table ever wait this is like what kind of
budget do we have here we can't even afford real tables real
desks for our employees health recovery health recovery per
element All right.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Screw you!
I don't know if I got him or not.
Ah!
Did they come down yet?
No they didn't.
Where'd they go?
Oh.
Yeah!
Oh!
We like...
I didn't realize we like get so close to them.
Cool.
Okay, we kind of like zoom at them.
Nice.
These guys are still chilling up there.
I guess I won't touch them.
You don't hurt me?
I don't hurt you.
It's fine.
We're cool.
We're chill.
Hold on.
There's other stuff over here.
What's this?
It's so dark.
Trench.
Dead letter approval.
Oh my god.
I get like a little, you know, um...
You do as you're told.
Don't eat mold.
What does that sound?
Oh my gosh.
Um, I get like a little tiny, like, achievement tracker
thing.
Every time I pick something up, it's like you're this much
closer to an achievement.
All right, let's keep going.
The mold looked awfully tasty, though.
Can't go here.
Gotta go up here.
Around here.
Something's like screaming.
It's scaring me.
Oh geez.
I
think I got him.
Let's control this area!
Let's cleanse it!
Oh yeah!
Some doors open when you clear the control point.
Oh, okay, cool.
Good.
Wow.
Ooh.
Navigate through the communications department.
Will do.
Cleanse control points again, fast travel.
Yeah.
Fast travel is always nice.
There's something cool here, is there?
We're on the right track.
Yes, we are.
Not quite yet, though.
Yeah, but first we loot.
First we take it.
What's this?
Our natural top...
Dr. Darling.
It is wide and capable of storing a whopping 80 kilobytes.
80 kilobytes!
Stolen by our friends at the CIA, the disk held the launch
codes to Soviet nukes.
And the launch codes.
I'm looking at the launch codes.
A perfect fusion of concepts vibrating in the Cold War era
collective unconscious.
A receptacle.
It is a receptacle for dangerous energies to hone in on.
I don't trust this guy.
We don't have the details, but when things started flying
around the disk, it was transferred to us.
Flying around.
It's an object of power.
An OOP.
Oops.
Pencils.
Do you recognize anything about Dr. Darling?
Can't say that I do.
Give me a hint.
Why, yeah, why'd you throw pencils at us?
He's so rude.
What's going on there?
Alright, hold on.
Let's...
We're gonna loot again.
There's some doors down here now that are open.
I'm guessing everything that I got in here before is fine.
The voice.
Wait, though, the voice does sound familiar, though.
His voice does sound very familiar.
Baby car!
Thanks for the fine get there!
Dead presidents.
Oh, wait.
director trench um i'm the director now my name is dr
darling i'm a scientist no we're done no that's not that's
him that's my writer that's my writer Oh my god!
Oh my god, my rider!
Where did he become a doctor?
Now do I trust him?
Even less.
No, John Wick.
No!
Alan Wick.
Wake.
Alan Wake.
Dang it.
You put John Wick in my head.
It's not my fault.
Alan Wake Face Reveal?
Real not clickbait?
He...
He just had a change of careers.
Or something.
Alan wake me up inside.
Anyway, I'd like to thank you for approving my request for
the Dead Letters Archive.
Cataloging the Bureau's collection of delinquent mail will
provide an extremely handy database that research teams can
use to search for any connections or related topics found
among the letters.
Aside from the more functional purposes, the archive will
allow us to preserve these windows into authentic human
encounters with the paranormal world.
The letters came to us from various places and times
gathered by the Postal Service as undeliverable.
The Bureau is the perfect home for them.
I realize not all letters contain accounts of genuine
paranormal events but even the erroneous ones allow us
insight into how the unknown is perceived by real people oh
they're so out of touch they can't even i mean i guess if
you work at a place like this you see so much paranormal
stuff supernatural and then you kind of are just like what
would what would a normal person consider weird anymore you
know what i mean of course i will first But they are so like
out of touch, they can't even remember what something weird
would be.
Of course, I will still...
Wait, I will first compile a system to allow us to analyze
the letters for any information or suspected connections to
AWEs and other alternate materials.
So thank you again.
Can't wait to delve into my dead letters.
P. Bartwell.
To whom it may concern.
I am being contacted by the past presidents of the United
States of America.
Spirit guides giving me their wisdom.
Okay, so this is one of those freaky letters.
And so it was the one of the guy that made the phone to God.
Dead letter mail is a mail that cannot be delivered to the
addressee or the return sender.
Yeah, yeah.
Have you guys ever been to one of those places that, like,
takes undeliverable packages and then resells them?
They've always made me a little bit uncomfortable.
But they're like, oh, yeah, we couldn't deliver this mail
package.
So, uh...
you can buy it now and it's kind of like a mail gotcha you
might get a gucci purse or you might get i don't know a pair
of chopsticks who knows those exist they unfortunately do
like it's it feels a little strange you can you can look it
up that's a japan thing no i've only i've seen it i'm only
i've seen it in the united states yeah you might get
someone's insulin Woohoo!
There's a shop here that only sells Amazon returns.
How do they get them?
It's yeah.
It feels illegal but isn't.
It really does, doesn't it?
Like it's I guess it's like after a certain amount of time,
I don't really know.
Maybe they're just like lying also.
Maybe they like buy things and keep them in the packages,
you know?
to make it seem like it's lost male and then they just buy
rubber bands from Timu and I don't know it's it's it's a
male gotcha though it's kind of crazy I don't know I've
never tried it I never will it kind of freaks me out anyway
um the presidents of the United States they appear Spirit
guides giving me their wisdom John Adams keeps saying I need
to fix America but I can't really understand him they all
they all have a lot of opinions people telling me I'm
imagining it but Theodore Roosevelt showed me how to fix my
lawnmower and I don't know a thing about lawnmowers explain
that how would Theodore Roosevelt how would Theodore
Roosevelt know how to fix a lawnmower though i have great
dead men telling me about the past and the present if you'd
like to use my abilities to help run the government please
let me know i know the white house could use me your yours
and earnest james bartholomew
am i doubting teddy roosevelt well i mean
when when is this taking place because I would like to think
that lawnmowers from the time that Theodore Roosevelt like
was alive until now in the game I would like to believe that
they are a little different 2019 now my lawnmower will has a
camera on it and scans the lawn and a funny AI will tell me
if all the blades of grass are equal length or something I
don't know when are we gonna have Roomba lawnmowers that's
what I'm wondering does let her loose just they exist
already no way technically the first gas motor lawn go gas
motor lawn mower was 1902 teddy passed away in 1919 plus
it's teddy what's a lawn mower versus san juan hill i don't
know don't we already have that don't we wait i know the
pool cleaners the pool cleaners have been around for a long
time because i used to haunt a place with a pool and i would
watch the pool cleaner as like a extracurricular activity.
I was like, it was...
I wasn't getting anything for it.
It was like a hobby of me sitting and just watching the pool
cleaner go around.
Rumba lawnmower sound terrifying and incredibly dangerous.
How?
I think that's called autism.
Undiagnosed, by the way.
Don't diagnose me, internet!
You don't know what goes on in my brain.
They put bunny ears on the lawnmower room, but Tivoli
Gardens is very cute.
No way!
That's so cute.
Considering how primitive a lot of lawnmower engines are,
you can see Teddy having some insight.
That's fair.
trying to doubt the guy.
Oh wait, what's our multimedia?
Oh the floppy disk.
Back to everybody whispering in my... what's this one?
Avoid modern technology.
Freaky.
That is flashing in there.
What is it?
is this another letter book club oh my gosh I think it is
hello avid readers the bureau book bunch will convene at the
usual spot in the corner table of the cafeteria at 5 p.m.
on Tuesday currently discussing unless you by J.D.
Brooks hey I know an amazing author that you guys really
need to check out do lawn Roombas also have cat pilots
inquiring minds what to know i have nothing that i just want
to call the roosevelt historian guy a total nerd
tim thank you so much for the fight get did
unless you buy jd brooks everyone should get their reviews
to me by londay oh londay's one day one day before lunch so
i can generate some conversation starters before the meeting
happy reading penny bart will wait oh for some reason I
thought it was still there it was under book club never mind
one day munch yeah step into the f3
Let's join the Treasure Keys!
Hey Meg, what's wrong?
My mom's dead!
I'm so sorry Meg, what happened?
What happened?
They blocked it out!
It's like the director says.
Confidentia and children both start with C.
The director's a puppet.
Hey.
The theory.
I'm a four-person.
I could never.
Dad says my mama went missing in actions.
She walked into the city and didn't come back.
Save for control.
I don't know what missing in actions is, but I sure wish
someone would find her.
I'll help you, Luctofer.
We'll find your mama together.
What's wrong?
Why should I say it like that?
Why are you looking at me?
We're just gonna get...
Oh.
We're gonna make sure nobody else can watch that.
Who find their books like this?
Together.
Wait, if I destroy stuff, can I see more funny letters?
please show me more funny letters
so uncanny there's definitely something about that
um I can't yeah there was like the projector wait it's all
back to normal I definitely distinctly remember knocking it
over because I'm just like a brick wall 10 out of 10 show
yeah yeah don't eat the mold there is more there is more
okay Good to know.
Screw computers.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Oh, and there's something else over there, too.
We got house memory material.
And?
Singing fish.
Mr. Governor.
I called the police, but they never killed me.
to my house i got a problem you got the send you got to send
folk to fix it i got my wife i got my wife one of them
singing fish on the walls it's not a real fish it sings when
you hit a button but it's got the devil in it it flies
around at night and sings devil songs it says a lot of cuss
words the devil got in my house because of the fish and you
got to come handle it My wife is real upset.
Where can he come?
Sincerely, Dwayne Barr.
No, his wife is upset.
Anything else here?
Oh, yeah, that's right.
You guys don't have proper desks.
Poor Dwayne Barr and his wife.
Okay, that maybe is everything now?
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is just another way up.
Okay, cool.
Wait.
Oh, just kidding.
I thought it was something over there.
Does it even say darn and heck?
The amount of times I say, but it's got the devil in it.
Ooh, not good.
Ooh, spooky hallway.
Wait, okay.
Um, which way does up go?
Oh, toilet first?
Where the heck am I?
I think that means the communications department is...
I have no idea.
Oh, we're just exploring, it's fine.
Wonder what happened here.
Oh, okay, cool.
The wall signs are more useful than the map, so I've heard.
Wonder what happened here!
My bad.
I'm sorry, the floors are made of paper.
Shelter area this way.
Okay.
Hey!
Uh...
You okay?
Oh my god!
What happened to you?
How did he die?
You think he knows any death metal songs?
Surely, right?
He got bonked out but his eyes are wide open!
Okay, good.
There's no mold in this one.
Nice.
Book club again.
end book club notes for penny by l samson so i don't usually
read a lot of sci-fi but as far as space operas go this was
all right the title unless you could refer to a bunch of
things in the book i guess but i thought it was a little
vague and stupid the way the characters kept throwing it
around almost like a catchphrase got it real annoying real
fast this is number two out of five okay Samson had a lot of
a lot of thoughts the best part of the story was the space
battles I sided with the fixers obviously because they had
the coolest tech and their motives made the most sense to me
honestly if I had to choose between some hoity-toity flowers
and guns space hippies or a badass bunch of warriors who go
around devouring planets like cheap sushi on a Sunday I know
who I'm picking that scene where they invade city planet and
convert the entire population using those brain worms and
that space dog fight between those two ace pilots sign me up
can a book be an opera yeah I'm kind of confused about that
part too what kind of what kind of ruined the whole thing
for me was when my favorite character got killed not even
halfway through the story by getting a battery cylinder
launched into his face isn't that kind of what we just saw
by a gravitational anomaly his death didn't feel at all.
I think that's what we literally just witnessed happen to
this dude over here.
Glutapy!
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Give this!
Space opera is like Star Wars.
Oh, I see.
Got some more material?
Are these little beds?
How cute!
If I go towards this.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
It hurts my brain.
I got it.
An object of power.
It's like, wow!
Crouch to take cover.
Okay.
Woo!
Uh, okay, down there.
Whoa.
Thank goodness this thing is indestructible.
All right.
Going around.
Going down.
Uh huh.
There's some, uh, oh there's okay, down.
What's over here?
Okay, some other stuff.
Can you see me?
Nah.
Shattered recoil efficiency.
Is he still shooting at me?
How do you even know?
Yeah, I'm sorry if there's like weirdo spam bots that are
like just saying nonsense I hold on let me try and get rid
of what the heck I don't know what what what sometimes bots
confuse me so much because I'm like what is your purpose
like I understand if it's a bot trying to get people to like
go to their hot cam sexy girl website but like a bot that
just spams nonsense makes no sense to me
I've had to take out a couple just today it's weird okay um
something tells me those things down there are not gonna
last so we're gonna run oh shoot crouch crouch i knew it i
knew it
okay uh let's go this way
something told me that the cardboard box would not be so
tough I don't know what told me, it's just an instinct, you
know?
Gamer instinct, probably.
It's the hiss, yeah.
Go, go, go!
Ow!
Okay, good.
Ooh, that was close.
Um, hmm.
Anything over here?
No, doesn't seem like it.
Alright, cool.
Ah.
The dead presidents told me, so true.
So what am I supposed to fix this thing?
Oh, I have to just cleanse it.
Run!
Cleansing you!
I'm cleansing you!
Oh my gosh, it's the floppy disk!
I'm getting the launch codes!
Telekinesis?
It's harder to hear you when I'm here.
It's like that channel's been changed The board's in charge
here They're pyramids in the bureau seal Are they really the
ones pulling the strings?
I'm not their director I'm no one's director Grab E E and E
Ah yeah Come
here little guys Come here little guys Do I have like a...
What's that do?
Oh.
That's not what I tried to get?
Oh, I see, I see.
Whoa.
I see, I see, though.
I see, I see.
Don't need the gun anymore.
But I feel safe with it.
You don't?
You don't feel safe with a gun?
Come on, I want to launch it at somebody.
Let me add them.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Wait, where's another one?
Leave me alone.
There's one.
Holy cow.
It's kind of OP.
Big guy, big guy.
You just rip a chunk out of the walls.
Oh, nice!
So I could just kind of, like, be like...
And then be like, yeah!
Okay, gotcha.
Very nice.
Take that.
Eat it up, eat it up.
Eat it up.
Oh, I don't even need to break it.
I don't even need to melee.
That's crazy.
Oh, sorry.
What did he say?
Seeking our astral plane.
There you are.
You were gone.
Cut off.
I got it.
Are those bad guys just like you wanted?
Right.
This will help me fight the hiss.
I don't, don't attack me.
My aim.
Where are you?
Oh.
Where'd he go?
There he is.
Oh, shoot.
There's a big guy.
Take him out?
Wait, it's so awesome.
Is that it?
Wow, it's so awesome.
No, I don't even need to aim.
She just does it itself.
It, like, locks onto them.
So good.
We love to see it.
I thought they were, like, friends at first.
Is there anything else in here?
I guess not, because we contained whatever that thing was,
so...
Everything else seems sealed up.
Die!
Oh, you're still- no.
Come here.
Look at the- Yeah.
That's right.
What's this?
Oh, something that I could just yank- Oh my gosh, now I
could just yank!
I could pick up everything!
I thought it was like me trying to make a phone call.
Woo!
That's a more Ruterial?
Emily said that the hotline can be reached through the mail
room.
Oh, I thought I'd be able to...
Oh my god.
This will be your bread and butter the return to monkey
power.
Enjoy throwing rocks you are now a poltergeist.
It's so awesome!
I guess you really don't need a gun anymore, huh?
Wait, then let's get rid of this weapon model.
Oh wait, I guess it doesn't really matter because it's only
for the...
This is for the health, that's right.
Okay, so we're still fine.
Monkey, monkey, I throw object!
I love that.
Oh, here's something.
The world is your gun now!
Willow A-W-E Outcome.
Uh, unread.
Oh, his demolition expert.
I don't...
I think I took that guy out before he did anything.
You sure extinguished him, huh, Minky?
Yeah, you keep one handgun for trick shots.
Of course, of course.
I'm not gonna, like, stop using it.
Oh, his ranger.
It's just telling me about the different guys.
Okay, that's fine.
the floppy disk eight-inch diskettes containing Soviet era
nuclear launch codes now they're all in my brain do you want
me to tell you the codes do you want me to tell you the
codes the
codes are in
seven oh
here we go Thomasie Thomasie the national news sites have
begun about publishing The story of the polar bear attack on
the Alaskan town.
Oh, they said don't mention Alaska.
Can you repeat that?
Oh, man.
It was like a one-time use.
Big boss stole those codes just for me, too.
Jokes on you, we can read lips.
What am I saying now, then?
What did I say?
Pretty sure I lip read 800135.
Well, I'm sorry, 8008135.
Of course, of course.
Wait, how did you know?
Stop, that scared me.
You really can read my lips.
I'm scared.
Wait, how did you know that I said that?
So rude.
I'm gonna go to the little ghosty's room.
Guys, I have to party real quick.
One second, I'll be right back.
I'm back.
One second.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, look!
I have my number!
4-4-4!
Oh, it's kind of hidden behind you guys, but 4-4-4-0!
How spooky!
Okay, it's a time!
Thank you!
Alright, let's read about this Willow AWA.
Thank you guys for all the same chats!
I plugged those codes into the number site.
And my goodness, Minto.
I didn't know you were into that.
Did I... Was I one-off?
Because if you're one-off, it gives you the super big...
booby ladies like the the the ladies that have such big
boobs that's their whole body when i mean super booby ladies
like there that's like they have no waist no legs they are
all boob
off went off in which way oh the codes work do we have an
hour left for the invasion of the booby ladies or what
new merch idea no no no you don't want to know the merch
idea that i took from an i saw it erogate at comic-cat and i
saw one of the merch that they had and i was like um setina
please that right now
not right now obviously uh we're trying to like somehow a
bunch of our merch launches they like kept getting pushed
back and now all of a sudden they're like on top of each
other so after my birthday there won't be anything for a
little bit so yeah what could it be you whatever you are
thinking you are probably wrong but also please don't feel
like you ever have to you know sometimes sometimes like you
know merch launches or like a certain merch won't be for you
and that's totally okay if you have to if you have to be
like ah i want to support minto but i can't afford all these
merch launches or or this one this one it's not really my
favorite thing but i still want to support her don't don't
don't do it it's okay you know please like it's totally okay
you don't have to buy the merch okay you don't have to buy
it it's okay yeah but just happy you're getting so many
opportunities like i said it kind of all happened where like
everything started piling up at once and i'm like ah but so
i decided um actually i was talking with my manager about it
today um in my weekly meeting but uh i decided that my i i
didn't really i i only came up with like two small things
for my birthday because I was like worried about the amount
of merch and stuff um so uh so I I only have a little bit of
stuff for for my birthday and then um the uh the summer
outfit my new outfit stuff will be around that time as well
so um it won't be another month until um the summer stuff
goes up and then you'll have a month I believe to pre-order
that if you so wish but um yeah so uh yes yes yes
that um will be uh that's that's the update on the summer on
the summer merch uh summer dress merch so the summer's merch
timeline has felt a bit compressed i know i'm so sorry i'm
so it really really didn't mean to do this I have been
bringing it up to being like um I'm really I'm worried that
everything is like too close together so yeah is the merch
where you put the pull the clothes because I saw videos of
those popping up during those days oh wait is it the merch
where you pull the clothes no pull the clothes oh like
there's like a kimakura and stuff where you can pull the
clothes off no no it's not like that no whatever you though
i saw some crazy stuff i probably
but yeah uh so yeah the summer my summer new outfit merch
will be um on my birthday along with uh two other things
that are birthday well one is not birthday exclusive well
there's actually only one birthday merch but that's okay
that's okay um it's just a little bit and I am asking them I
am asking them to have that pre-made so that you can get it
in time for spooky month um yes yes um just one merch but a
good one I hope so I like it spooky month yeah because my
birthday is October duh so yeah well there also be
pre-orders there should be there should be obviously the
summer merch will be pre-ordered but yeah just letting you
guys just keeping you guys updated you guys updated okay
alaskan polar bear bull worm you all know i don't like to
boast but claiming that the family was killed by migrating
polar bears desperate for food because their ecosystem is
being ruined by global warming was a stroke of genius using
current ecological concerns makes the public much less
likely to peep peep peep peep peep peep peep peep peep peep
peep peep speaking of merch my kai guy imports densitude.exe
minto happy arrived today i got a notification that Hot dog
is on its way.
Yippee!
My wallet hates me now.
Oh my gosh, Phil.
Well, thank you for supporting Marina because I love her
very much.
And thank you for getting the happy.
I'm sure it looks so good.
So another AWE behind us and the public is none the wiser.
Well done, everyone.
It was a strong campaign and perfectly executed.
This doesn't mean we can stop monitoring and for any
off-message opinions.
Oh, I read that as minions.
But it's looking like we're in the clear.
Tomasi out.
I heard...
I watched a video...
Today of some mom being like, Don't go taking your child to
the new minions and monsters movie.
It's so not appropriate.
They tie the minions up and they spank them.
And there's so many butts in the movie.
I almost took my child out.
And I was like, oh no, oh no, I accidentally bought a ticket
to the Minions of Monsters movie.
She's like, at one point she's like, there's, there's a part
where, where some, something goes up the Minions butt and he
goes, ow.
now you have to see i know how inappropriate is it
the horror i have who think of the children who is thinking
of the children oh goodness gracious so funny though all
right where where the heck are we and where the heck are we
going okay mailroom central executive cafeteria
We are currently somewhere.
Oh, I'm watching them like, wait.
Yeah, look at them go.
Cool.
Can I go in here?
Oh, I thought it was open.
Or, like, just blocked, you know.
Oh, wait a second.
I can!
Uh.
I'll take this.
in case somebody appears.
Anybody?
Anybody want to fight?
Anybody want a tango?
I'm glad I can just kind of hold on to it.
Clutching my pearls right now.
Scandalous minions.
Their butt was out.
Their butts were out.
Wait, this stuff is flying around, around it.
That's so cool.
they had one guy work in this whole room that's so sad never
thought of a minions but once in my life before today i bet
all the ants on facebook are going crazy they're going nuts
they're like oh my gosh finally new material
what did i get a ma Boom!
Headshot exclusive to spin grip shatter pierce.
Headshot damage plus 42%!
I could headshot!
Was there anything else in here?
Game just saved.
I'm not sure why.
Don't scare me.
With my aim?
Shut up!
I could headshot!
What are you talking about?
I've done many of them now.
Oh wait.
Okay, never mind.
I guess there's really nothing else in here.
This room is so huge, though.
Oh, there's two people.
Good, he had a buddy.
Look up.
I guess we continue onwards.
Big Grimm.
Whoa, whoa.
I want to go in there.
Oh, I can!
No, I can't.
Oh, come on.
Please!
I'm the director!
a key nearby i'm the director what's
all this oh control point
wait did this just this just open up or am i crazy i can
really just lift i could just lift everything how we got how
we oh this is just fast travel i was gonna say i was about
to ask how are we about our outfit but clearance level one
this must open the door yeah oh oh my goodness oh my god oh
my god i
think he's dead poor guy is this gonna be a boss wait but
there's so there have been so many
there have been i don't like this Why is it so dark in here?
There have been so many level one doors that I haven't been
able to open at this point.
What is that?
Oh.
I kind of want to go back to them, but...
Have I been in here?
I can't remember.
No, this is new.
Ah!
Socks and ballerinas.
Okay, I don't think I like this one.
Oh, toilet.
House memory.
We could go back.
Talk to me again.
I dare you.
Try to talk to me again.
Oh.
Wait, how did you also have a clue?
clearance level.
Wait, how'd you do that?
Something sounds so magical behind the window.
Everything in the kitchen sink.
Oh, that's health.
Uh-huh.
Ah!
Okay.
Mail room, cafeteria, central executive.
This is...
That is the room that we were just trying to get into.
I can't... The thing is is I want to go back to all the
clearance rooms that I haven't been able to go into.
But I...
I couldn't even begin to tell you...
What is this?
I couldn't even begin to tell you!
Wow!
Oh, shoot!
Where they are!
I think I got both of them.
Yeah.
I think I got them.
Oof!
I don't even mean to come in here.
At least it's quiet.
What's this?
Data breach.
We go blast in.
I feel so good with the tele- with the telekinesis.
Last month our on-site server experienced an intrusion by
unauthorized users.
it was confirmed that the users only accessed a video file
which contained portions of various Dr. Darling
presentations.
Investigators were able to track the users through their IP
addresses.
Oh, I'm getting doxxed!
They're getting doxxed!
I genuinely do not remember this room.
I don't think there are any miscibles in this game could be
wrong, though.
I don't know.
Maybe.
The following are the confirmed identities of these users.
Jacko.
These are all like Finnish names that I'll never be able to
pronounce.
Patrick Rubens, Arto, Christopher.
Jacko.
These individuals are in breach of Bureau Code 91 and have
been placed under surveillance by our external investigation
team.
Further action is pending.
Internet usage.
Wait, we're in the internet.
Network disconnected.
We're in the internet room.
Internet is not for social media use.
No internet.
FBC materials of any kind may be scanned or uploaded.
FBC email addresses are for work-related correspondence
only.
Level 5 clearance required to access the internet.
If a cubicle's black rock shell gets damaged, vacate it
immediately and alert Dr. Oh, not Dr. Mr. Tomasi.
Oh, that guy.
If you notice any text in your work that you do not recall
writing, vacate your cubicle immediately and alert Mr.
Tomasi.
devices to the network printers for communication department
use only altered items are forbidden in the cubicles notify
security if of any breaches immediately they may require
internal lockdown neat this guy's still trying to sell his
acoustic guitar there
is there anything I can I guess I guess we got that one
thing, right?
You'll buy it?
Level, level.
Oh, that don't look good over there though.
Wait, is that the mold?
That's mold!
This is why I'm director now.
Why would you put mold?
Oh my god.
You hear some music.
I wish I had a...
I wish I had a flashlight.
Can I pick up this lamp?
Don't breathe it in.
But there's something there.
We'll have to come back.
We'll have to come...
Oh, there's something here too.
Lockdown distinctions.
Yeah, I'm director because they put mold under a cell.
secondary alerts, and I'm telling you, it's been a number
one of my priorities.
If I vote for me for director because I hold mold very
seriously.
Pay attention, Alberto.
This is the last time I'm explaining this.
Internal lockdowns are manually triggered events that lock
one or all of the sectors by restricting use of the sector
elevator.
Effectively locking staff in their sector until Bureau of
Control it would be the hold and the miss oh yeah you'd vote
for me thank you thank you no mold we have a strict zero
mold policy in Minto we trust but the mold is delicious this
guy is already gotten got by the mold parasites guards you
know what to do old yeller protocol initiated
They can be lifted via the directorial override and
maintenance once the director is satisfied that the
situation is under control.
Mold the elder.
External lockdowns are a bigger deal.
Nothing in or out of the whole building.
It's only triggered by a code red containment breach based
on some complicated system that security and research
slapped together.
it can only be lifted once a the threat has been neutralized
and b a high clearance individual gives the system the all
clear this process is not the same as the directorial
override so stop saying it's so in documentation i know it's
confusing as hell i've told darling a hundred times to
change it but they're adamant it stays the way it is
honestly i don't think they even know how to change it at
this point let's just make sure our staff understand how all
this how this mess all works okay marshall
all righty um yeah i was gonna try and find some of the uh
level one doors that exist in some locations that i quite
truly can't remember but i also can't remember so we're not
gonna go or we could fast travel to like a past area or
something nah we'll go through here it's fine
Yeah, let me in.
Oh, golly.
What is this?
Wow.
Uh-oh.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, no.
Is it just him?
Ouch.
Oh, holy cow.
Okay.
they can fly now interesting watch out for the grenade
warning indicator okay wow he like dodged my first thing I
don't know if he had dodged it or if it was just like an
unlucky throw and he moved as soon as I threw it
oh no all my oh but it did keep my stuff right wait did it
save like my fight and everything that I did up here and all
the stuff that I got in here.
He dodged.
What a...
Okay, that stayed open.
Like, there was this guy we killed over here.
Okay.
They stayed dead.
Saves all the stuff you collect.
Okay.
Seems like it.
Wait.
Oh, I missed something, though!
America overnight to america overnight episode 300 and
something at 59 years thank you for staying up with us
ghosts ghosts we've had many callers over the years tell us
of haunties voices and other phantasmagorical phenomena
today friend of the show dr quincy reagan tells his story
quincy thanks this is something i experienced recently while
staying at the chili pines motel in for last year's making
bacon suspicion gone I was in room 47 the night manager an
avid listener of the program insisted I take this particular
room also there's a bunch of text there explained that years
back the body of a man was discovered under the bed inside
that wooden border that motel beds tend to have and the body
had been there a week he said guests had stayed there
sleeping with the I was gonna say the smell though.
Hauntings have been reported in room 47 ever since.
I happily took the room.
I fell asleep pretty quick.
Checking under the bed first, of course.
No ghosts visited me.
What?
No chilly spots or flickering lights.
But?
When I woke up, I found myself under the bed.
Ew, that's disgusting.
That's actually gross.
Luckily, I was able to push the mattress off and crawl out
before I suffocate.
The night manager was kind enough to find me another room.
Oh, there you have it, listeners.
What we call ghosts taking many forms.
Quincy was brave enough to tell his story, and I encourage
you to keep calling and writing whenever you encounter
something you see.
Oh my God.
That's like an actual horror story.
Like, maybe your toaster is possessed.
Remember, dear listeners, when no one else believes you, we
do.
America overnight, we'll be right back.
Have you ever accidentally dropped something under your bed
in a hotel room and you have to look under there?
And it's like a whole other ecosystem?
Horrifying.
Also, I like this.
Who wrote this?
Darling.
Somewhere among the line, things went weird.
No one was sure on how this happened, whether it was
something caused by someone or something, or if it just
happened by itself.
There was a lot of stories.
Everyone had a theory of how it happened, of which maybe the
weirdest.
And something only fittingly singled out.
Who did this?
Okay.
I found a half-eating cookie under my...
I'm kind of off, Kai.
Like, it's the worst feeling because you're like, oh my
gosh, they didn't properly clean this.
Wait, I'm double checking.
Okay, so this is now open.
Okay, so, wow, it really does save everything.
That's pretty nice.
Okay, cool.
Uh, this room.
Oh my gosh, how am I supposed to defeat this thing?
He's, like, insane.
My thing is, is I don't really...
Is there a dodge?
Hold on.
I'm checking, like, the controls.
There's just sprint.
Shield.
Evade.
Hold on.
Does that work?
Use cover.
I guess that would make the most sense, huh?
No, you can't dodge now.
Oh, I don't have it yet.
Okay, okay.
Then we use the cover.
Yeah.
The weeb ghosts keep showing up in my recommended and I keep
clicking on her video.
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, let's try.
I'm preemptively crouched.
Eek!
Oh, they can fly now.
Great.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, it's Dr. Tomasi!
Mr. Tomasi, whatever his name is.
Holy cow.
Oh shoot, that was close.
Okay, we're just gonna do a bunch of covering.
Oh, come on.
It's fine, we're fine.
Oh, he dodges it for sure.
Okay.
Okay, this is fine.
Oh, he's got more people covered.
That's funny.
Okay, we're reloading.
Oh, my health though.
Oh, shoot.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, that guy.
Right there.
Get him.
Oh, come on.
Is he coming over this way?
Come on.
Ah!
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, get out of here.
Mr. Okay, we can grab the health now.
Alright.
Okay.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Shoot.
Whoops!
Ouch!
Holy cow!
I thought I would be okay in here.
Oh, shoot!
There's a guy over there!
You son of a gun!
Okay, another guy coming at me.
Wait, I didn't get her better off.
Okay.
I need more health!
Oh my god, this is tough.
This is tough, this is tough.
Okay, I'm not even kidding this dude.
I got him so powerful.
Where is...
Where is this dude, though?
Oh my god, the doctor is gone.
Ah, I can't even...
I'm trapped under here.
Oh, please.
Leave me alone.
Where'd he go?
Where'd they go?
Oh, he does dodge everything.
Okay.
Okay,
gotta double check.
There's no guys trying to, you know, do that to me.
All right.
Oh, come on.
Hi.
His dodge has a cooldown.
Does it now?
Oh, shoot.
That's a lot of guys.
Nice.
Okay, let's think.
I have to run to the other side and grab some health.
There we go.
Oh, shoot.
That's right.
I can't tell if he's getting me or if I am, like, exploding
things in my face.
You know?
I
don't see.
Oh, I see some health over there.
Okay, run, run, run.
Grab the health.
Yoink.
Making sure he didn't summon anybody.
Struggling on the first boss.
We love to see it.
Oh
my god, please, please, what has she?
Yeah, maybe.
Phase two?
Surely not on a first boss.
I have a feeling he'll be back.
This guy's waving at me.
What do you want?
Let's stay focused.
The hotline should be past the mailroom.
and grab some of the health that's around here too.
Awesome.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, there's a lot of guys down here.
Oh wow, nice, nice, nice!
Oh, perfect.
What is that?
Oh, it's a lamp.
He's yelling for help.
Some quality veto noises this stream.
Glad to think so.
Let's see.
What's...
up here.
Anything?
Just some more health?
Good job, thank you!
It was a bit of a tough not to crack, wasn't it?
Oh, come on!
Yeah, that's right.
We'll unlock things as we can.
Oh!
Their pained faces amuse me.
Hi, Minto.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
The hotline chamber.
Alright, take this down.
The situation in Cuba has been evaluated by the relevant
authorities.
The mysterious illness affecting the staff at the U.S.
Embassy in Havana was caused by Sonic the weaponry in the
hands of a foreign power.
Numerous personnel have damage to the inner ear.
It's just like that room in Grim Fanzhenko.
To make a full recovery.
Of course the event also damaged their cellular walls, but
we can't blame that on some stupid noise gun Thank god no
local doctors examine them first Honestly, we're the odds of
all tonight and we show up inside a US embassy talk about
good luck, huh?
So much easier to...
Are you still recording this?
It's crazy that this is confirmed true wait seriously?
That's crazy actually though Alberto Tomasi head of comms We
got it.
Collect 40 collectibles.
What personal mod did I get?
Energy recovery.
So I'm guessing the energy recovery is the thing for my
telekinesis, right?
Projectile spread.
Exclusive to shatter.
Okay.
Yeah, okay, okay.
That's why I didn't know what it was before.
Hiss elevated.
This guy.
It's possible that these individuals are bound to objects of
power prior to corruption.
Half of...
Yeah, embassy staff getting sick was a real thing.
Oh.
Interesting.
Wait, we got some codes here.
Well done, everyone.
It was a strong campaign and perfectly executed.
Oh.
What are the codes?
What do they mean?
The hiss got him.
Butt summary.
Oh, my...
Alright.
Tell me more.
A spade of disappearances was traced to a home in the city
which...
A city of butt.
Where bureau agents discovered a translocative light switch
cord.
Why?
Bureau agencies arrived at the home of a local celebrity
located at...
Which has been connected to a total of disappearances in the
area.
Agents found no one inside.
While searching a closet, an agent pulled the light switch
cord and disappeared from view.
Another agent was selected to pull the cord in order to
replicate the event.
He disappeared as well.
Both agents were discovered at the oldest house.
Days later.
Found in a sealed room by rangers exploring a new area of
the house.
There's still areas of the house that haven't been explored
yet.
That's why.
But it does say it's AWE17.
So maybe it's...
Yeah, 1992.
It's like an old event.
Wow.
The light switch cord in the butt's home closet disappeared
during this incident.
Yeah, I live in butt.
Oh.
I'm from butt.
Nothing funny about it.
House memory.
I wonder when I'm going to be able to use this.
The hotline can't be far now.
Right.
Surely.
Oh.
Hilariously, I just saw a true crime scene where someone
mispronounced but but but is a but?
Odd recurring theme.
I can.
All right.
Let's get this hotline, baby.
Is this it?
Oh, wait.
I think I hear something ringing for real.
The butt supplement.
According to their testimony, the agents had been
transported from the butt home to a roadside motel named the
Ocean View Motel and Casino.
That's why they were there!
And discovered a room key by performing a ritual.
C-File MOT01, the key opened a door marked with an inverted
black pyramid, which they only learned after a lengthy
period of trial and error.
After pulling another motel cord found inside the room, they
were transported to the oldest house.
disappearances of the home's owner and the other locals of
but have been attributed to the light switch cord.
The ocean view.
Oh, oh, I keep saying wait, oh, it is ocean view.
They've typoed it here.
The ocean view motel is now known to have many doors and
pathways.
Butte.
Oh, she a butte.
since the occurrence identical light switch cords to the one
found in the but home has been appearing throughout the
oldest house at the time of writing beep beep light cords
have been found in the oldest house located in the beep beep
and beep beep sectors these all like access the ocean view
motel though how exactly this link operates is but initial
hypothesis hypotheses center on the butt A-W-E as a beep
beep.
I want to go home.
Home.
Hotline chamber.
Director use only.
Disregard of this policy may result in fatal psychic trauma.
Me every time someone one guys me.
You have fatal psychic trauma.
I wonder if these are devs wait what did i just pick up
maybe nothing so every stream not every stream right the
ocean view motel and casino green light the light switch
court one
more we've been here before traverse the ocean view motel
i've stated a lot of roadside motels across the country on
the road the black pyramid run under the radar this feels
like all of them like something recognized from a dream
cool though guys i think i will call it here and we will
traverse the hotel next time.
It was...
Wow, it was so cool!
So I'm really enjoying it so far.
This game is so stylish, right?
Oh.
Yeah, well, well, I want to start playing these on
Saturdays, but if I am taking too long and don't get to it
before October, I'll probably do some like twice a week or
something but this is cool very very cool I hope you guys
enjoyed part one of of control so yeah it is a yeah it is a
fairly long game so we'll see how how long but it's it's
fine I like taking my time on things anyway so i've had to
do twice a week that's a okay but yeah it's it's very
interesting it's not at all what i expected and i didn't
know what to expect at all so i'm very interested in
uncovering more stuff and i i really the thing i'm most
fascinated about right now are like the different cases like
like this with the with the with the cord and things like
that like kind of just the other awe's that they've
encountered before and reading up on those um and what
happened so yeah really cool really cool so thank you guys
for your help as well and um yeah i i could see the sap
comparison for sure for sure especially like that jukebox
that was in the cage very curious about that when we learn
about it dorko thank you so much for the big thank you Thank
you.
Oop.
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you.
Thanks for the strain control.
It's been so cool so far.
Hope your throat feels good.
And you have a wonderful night.
Thank you.
Love the black outfit.
Awesome.
Yeah, we'll keep, we'll keep the cool, the cool outfit for,
uh, for, um, control.
Mmm.
Otsumito everybody.
I'm gonna go eat dinner because I'm home.
I've recently, I've found like a, what do you call?
A, um.
Uh.
Oh my gosh.
A Vietnamese place by me.
And they have like some awesome coffee.
Like awesome Vietnamese coffee.
But it is, it's so strong and makes me like.
And hungry.
Awesome, I thought everybody.
Awesome, I thought.
Yeah.
Bye bye.
have a good day have a good night bye bye thank you
everybody thank you thank you bye bye bye bye
guys look at this sick dutch angle i just made in in photo
mode whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait
That's perfect.
Okay, bye.